[Música]
Bienvenidos en la sandino desde Ecuador
en esta emisión hablaremos de la ola de
violencia que se ha vivido dentro de las
cárceles del país andino donde cada
revuelta desde las prisiones está
relacionada con enfrentamiento entre
bandas rivales por ganar nuevos
territorios en las calles a favor del
narcotráfico analizaremos Cuáles son las
causas que incrementan los motines
carcelarios y la pérdida del control de
los centros penitenciarios por parte del
Estado además conoceremos algunas de las
historias de personas que estén en por
la seguridad de sus familiares que
permanecen dentro de los recintos
carcelarios y comentaremos cuáles son
las estrategias que está implementando
el gobierno para recuperar el control de
las cárceles
[Música]
448 homicidios se produjeron entre el
año 2021-2022 dentro de las cárceles de
Ecuador un incremento de 4.280 por
ciento con respecto a las cifras del
2010 Cuando solo 10 personas eran
asesinadas dentro de los centros
penitenciarios se estima que la
tendencia de las muertes de presidiarios
continuará al alza luego que se
contabilizaran 11 masacres carcelarias
producidas entre febrero de 2021 y
noviembre de 2022 desde el año 2010 al
2017 el promedio de asesinatos fue de 10
personas al año dentro de las cárceles
en el 2018 se incrementó a 15 privados
de libertad 32 asesinatos en el año 2019
58 en el año 2020 6 cárceles de cinco
ciudades del país acumulan la mayor
cantidad de muertes originadas por el
control de territorios y rechazo a
traslados de reos hacia otros centros
penitenciarios del país las disputas
entre las bandas por apoderarse de
territorios se libran desde las calles
explica este experto en seguridad estas
organizaciones internacionales les
pagaban a las Nacionales con dólares y
desde aquel momento empiezan a pagarles
en droga ese es un cambio sustancial
porque eso no es obliga a las nacionales
a vender esa droga en el mercado local
Carrión asegura que el negocio de la
droga genera un consumo de 80 a 100
toneladas al año los reos buscan
mantener El dominio de las calles desde
las cárceles una vez que son capturados
asegura los especialistas según el
informe de drogas del año 2022 de las
Naciones Unidas Ecuador fue el tercer
país con mayor número de captación de
droga en el mundo después de los Estados
Unidos y Colombia en las cárceles los
privados de libertad son clasificados
dependiendo de las organizaciones
delictivas a las que pertenecen y no por
el delito cometido los homicidios dentro
y fuera de las cárceles superaron el
promedio de la región
en el año 2022 Ecuador alcanzó la tasa
más alta de muertes violentas de la
última década 15,48 muertes por cada
100.000 habitantes según cifras de la
Policía Nacional en los primeros 8 meses
hubo
2784 muertes violentas significan 348
asesinatos por mes normalmente
relacionado con las drogas y otros
delitos de continuar esta tendencia al
cierre del año Ecuador habrá superado
las 4.000 muertes alcanzaría una tasa de
22,2 homicidios por cada 100.000
habitantes superando el promedio de
latinoamérica de 17,2 según las Naciones
Unidas estas cifras inquietan a
familiares de reos que permanecen en las
cárceles y temen por sus vidas nosotros
estamos sufriendo mis hijos lloran
sufren enferma de del papá de mi esposo
también tanto le sufro porque aquí hay
bastantes
rumores que mata bastante delincuentes
ahí sí es bastante preocupante porque
últimamente en el Ecuador hasta
suscitando las
revueltas no sabemos por qué motivo Yo
estoy aquí hace he tenido mi esposo hace
tres años a lo mejor se puede decir que
la Justicia del Ecuador es mala
22 organizaciones delictivas operan
dentro y fuera de las cárceles según el
gobierno nacional desde los 32 centros
penitenciarios del país que se disputan
el control de los territorios decomisos
de droga fusiles municiones cuchillos
celulares y dinero en efectivo son
constantes en las prisiones en un
intento por mejorar la situación el
presidente de la república Busca la
cooperación internacional con los
gobiernos de los Estados Unidos e Israel
también la reducción de hacinamiento la
instalación de escáners y cámaras para
las cárceles
se transmite es parte de nuestra
solución integral para tener un mejor
control en los centros de detención como
lo estamos haciendo
y terminar con los hechos de violencia
que allí han ocurrido en los últimos
tiempos
por el momento la acción más expedita
del gobierno para solucionar la crisis
carcelaria será sacar la calle a 30.000
nuevos policías y graduar nuevos guías
penitenciarios elevando de 1500 a 3000
custodios para el control de una
población de 35.000 privados de libertad
medida que consideren suficiente la
Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos que continuó los hechos
violentos ocurridos en el país y le
exigió el gobierno de Guillermo lasso
implementar acciones concretas para
garantizar la seguridad y los Derechos
Humanos durante el gobierno de Guillermo
lasso se declararon estados de sección
el hacinamiento la reducción de
presupuestos el incremento de las penas
de separación del Ministerio de Justicia
en el año 2018 fueron los ingredientes
para un caldo de cultivo que afianzó los
enfrentamientos entre prisioneros que se
han hecho cotidianos en el país andino
hasta aquí esta emisión de enlace andino
desde Ecuador les invito a seguir con la
programación de France 24 en español
Gracias por acompañarnos hasta la
próxima